Hello, buddy.
Hello.
Well,
I'm not a person today.
As always, welcome to the 1230 Streams.
Wow, yippee.
It is.
Okay, I turned it down.
Let me just turn it all the way down.
You don't need to listen to that game.
You don't need to listen to me.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm not okay right now.
As always, at 1230, I'm never okay.
I just realized I forgot to...
I forgot to eat something real quick.
Well, I'm not eating any food at the moment because it's 1230.
Yippee.
I'll just eat right after the 1230 streams.
But I'll need to get that, you know, the throat...
The Chinese throat medicine thingy.
I forgot what it's called.
Because I made two streams today, I should get one of that for today's stream.
I'll be right back.
That's fine.
I clearly just...
I literally just started.
I'll be right back.
Give me five minutes.
I told you...
It was less than five minutes.
Whoa!
Also, you're gonna hear some squeaky noises because I bought Dad a new toy.
So, like, just to keep him occupied and, like...
Not depressed, you know?
Alright.
Let me... Let me...
Get this...
Not medicine.
This...
Thing in my mouth.
Good morning, Doki.
Good morning, Homo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good morning, Doki.
You sound trippier ass.
Thank you.
I mean, this is the...
The most happiest I've ever sounded at 1230 in the morning.
Sorry, I'm making sure...
Okay, it's the...
Nin...
Ninjong Pei Pa Koa.
I like how I pronounce that in the most fucking English accent ever.
Even though I'm Chinese...
Like...
I know Chinese.
Chinese...
The Chinese part of my brain has not...
Like...
Been activated...
For some reason.
Oh...
I'm...
Like...
I just...
Went full on English accent on that.
In the most non-Asian way possible.
I think if I spoke in a Chinese accent or like, you know, not Chinese accent because it's literally Chinese.
I read this in a more Chinese way of speaking.
I don't even know.
Sorry, I don't think it's activated right now.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is Koa.
I might be pronouncing it horribly wrong.
I was like, the fuck is this?
How do I make Koa sound like Chinese?
I don't know.
I'm reading the English pronunciation.
I'm like, I don't fucking know.
I'm too tired.
All right, this way.
Okay.
My voice sounds a little bit better now because I just, um, I just had, uh, just did the, I just ingested that.
So now I sound less dead inside, but it won't fix how I feel, how I actually feel.
It's like a little Band-Aid.
Did you guys know that Minecraft created green milk?
Sorry, I didn't know how to, I didn't know how to, like, uh, segue into it.
So I'm just gonna drop that in.
You know how?
It's just out of nowhere.
Did you know that Minecraft made creeper milk?
And I thought it was so, like, I don't know.
I feel like it was so unfortunately named, uh, that it was, it was named, uh, creeper milk.
Yes, so I'm assuming, like, did they milk some creepers?
I should have talked about this yesterday.
Did they milk some creepers to get creeper milk?
So if you Google image, um, you just gotta Google image, uh, uh, uh, uh, creeper milk, and then you'll, you'll get it.
But don't worry, you don't have to Google image creeper milk, because I can show you what it looks like, the convenience of being a streamer.
So yeah, so, it's literally milk that's green, and then it's called vanilla, yeah, I, I don't understand why it's called creeper milk.
And why, I don't, they just call it Minecraft milk, um, because then it just implies that you're milking the creeper.
Like, you're, like, you're, like, Phil, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, intruder alert.
There's a red spy in the bay, oh my, I do sound so much more alive now.
But in the inside, I am still dead inside, so, um, but that's okay, as long as my outside is alright.
Alright, I...
Guys, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I bet the hazard pay for milking creepers is pretty good.
Yeah, that's, like, then it's, like, makes me think, like, what are the logistics of milking a creeper?
Like, because it, they sizzle, right?
So, like, I assume you have to build an automated, an automated machine, so, like, you won't die from, like, being there.
But then you have to, I guess you push the creeper into a cart, and then you push it into the automated machine, so it automates milking a creeper to get the milk that you want.
But then, like, there's no automated machine to milk cows.
So, it's, like, Minecraft has to...
So, then, like, so, because, like, why couldn't it just be, like, Minecraft cow milk?
Why does it have to be creeper?
Like, how do, how do creepers lack...
I mean, I assume that it's, like, under there.
Like, we don't see it.
I assume...
I know they've made, like, other...
Wait, okay.
Uh, true...
Moo...
Milk.
I see...
They said they made, like, other colors.
Because they're, like, oh, it's the same company that made...
Blank.
I was, like...
Made what?
What else have they made?
Oh, they made blue milk!
They made the...
The Star Wars blue milk.
So...
So, they've done that.
So, they're, like, you know what would be even better than blue milk?
Creeper milk.
But it's literally just milk that's...
I didn't know...
You can just dye the color of milk and it'll be okay.
Because, like...
I assumed that, like...
I know, like...
Oh, wait, did they ever make Shrek milk?
I know...
Wait, Shrek...
Oh, they did!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Nesquik!
Nesquik did something like that.
Okay, but that green looks, like...
It looks wrong.
Okay.
Like, at least, like, Creeper milk looks okay.
But Shrek milk looks...
Really wrong.
No, I remembered...
I remembered watching a video that talked about all the different products Shrek has done.
Because it was, like, you know, capitalism, yeah.
And they won...
At one point, they talked about, like, Shrek milk.
And, like...
I would say...
This looks incredibly wrong.
I...
Especially when they called it Shrek's milk.
Because then, you know, you could...
It looks...
Where did they get this?
It looks very wrong.
Zybo, thank you, Liz.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Dirty, I just got here.
I'm worried.
The hell are you talking?
I'm just talking about milk, guys.
Also, like...
Am I supposed to drink 1% or 2% milk?
Because, like...
I don't know.
I...
I could never tell.
Why is there different percentages of milk?
Anyway.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It doesn't matter.
Then why are they separating percentages?
Why do you...
Oh, it's...
I'm just, like...
Why...
Just...
Why do they separate the milk percentages?
Why is...
Why...
Why is milk...
Why is milk, like, categorized into different things?
That is not milk.
I don't...
Like...
I can't say what it reminds me of.
I can't...
I can't really say what it actually looks like.
But it doesn't look like milk.
It doesn't...
I'll just say it.
It doesn't look like milk.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
JL, thank you, thank you.
Exhausted Doki needs a fluffy comforter and an air conditioner and some hot coal.
That sounds really nice right now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
PickleCucumber.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm just going to leave it on screen for now while I read these super chats.
JL, he has me invested in a method of milking creepers.
My, Oship.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look Shrek in the eye in the bag as you ask why the milk is yellow.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So when is... Alright, I'm not finished reading that D-Dragon.
Pebble, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just came from the clip about you and Milk talking about being lactose intolerant to open the stream and immediately be hit with creeper lactation.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, speaking of lactose intolerant, apparently, I read that, um, I read, like, you guys were talking about it in my comment sections on that vibe.
And I read that someone was saying that, like, we develop lactose intolerance, like, um, as we get older.
So I thought that was, and then, like, apparently it's a thing that almost every mammals do, that people, they just started becoming lactose intolerant.
as they get older, just to, like, discourage them from taking all the milk from babies.
I was like, what the...
So if it wasn't for our lactose intolerance, we would not be, I guess we won't be drinking milk out of gardens anymore.
So, I mean, I guess that makes sense.
But then, like, The thing is, I also know that, like, um...
I guess, like, okay, so, for those who don't know, I've talked about this before, but, uh...
Uh...
Sorry, child!
Daddy needs his milkies!
That's a wild sentence!
Um...
But that's where my mind was going towards it.
It's true!
Ha, ha, ha, ha...
Ha, hahh...
Ha, ha fø, ha, ha!
Ha, ha, ha...
Ha... ha, ha, ha...
Ha, ha ha...
Ha, ha, ha...
Ha, ha하, ha...
Anyway...
Um... I talked about it before, but for those who don't know, um, there's a...
Um, there's a higher, uh...
There's a higher chance for Asians to be, like, lactose intolerant than it is for, like, others.
Because, like, I think it was, like, something how, like, we didn't grow up.
Like, milk was not as common in Asia as it was for the rest of the world.
And that's why, like, they introduced, like, banana milk.
Because it was a way to get more people to drink milk back then.
And just because, like, a lot of Asians had a bigger tendency to develop lactose intolerance versus, like, the rest of the people around the world.
And that means the people around the rest of the world were bigger freaks than us.
If you think about it.
Because we were, you know, we were, like, we're not drinking milk after we're out of babies.
But then the rest of the world was, like, I need my milkies.
And you, like, forced through your genetic coding to be able to keep drinking milk.
I need my milkies.
Because then, that also means that you guys were, like, the rest, like I said, you guys.
Because I'm Asian.
I'm, like, I'm not a freak.
My ancestors were not freaks.
Yippee.
But I'm not lactose intolerant.
So, like, maybe part of my ancestry had freaks in there.
So, like, back then, back then, some of them were, like, I refuse to be lactose intolerant.
I shall have my milkies.
And then you found a cow and was, like, I'm drinking.
You're, like, you found a cow and you're just, like, if he can drink the milkies, I can drink the milkies.
That's crazy.
They have...
Um.
Uh.
Let's see.
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b.
Rag, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh.
I was diagnosed with being lactose intolerant last week.
After 34 years of drinking milk.
So sad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, I don't have lactose intolerant.
I'm not lactose intolerant.
So, like, I don't know exactly what happens.
Uh.
I guess, like, thank you to my ancestors for being freaks.
To make sure that I can, uh.
To make sure that, uh.
I can drink it.
Uh.
But, like, um.
Um.
I assume, like, you just go to the bathroom more.
So, it's not, like, that big of a sacrifice.
I feel like.
Like.
Um.
At best, you just be more dehydrated.
So, just drink more water.
Or you could just drink more milk.
Like.
Ha ha ha.
I just.
Yeah.
Oh.
Or more.
Okay.
I guess the stomach pain is not the best either.
Uh.
So.
Oh.
Doki.
You also forgot the intense pain.
Um.
Oh, yeah.
That seems.
Well.
What if you just get.
Okay.
What do we do pre-prep.
Pre-prep it before you.
You drink milk.
Like, you know.
Like.
You get Tylenol.
Or, like, painkillers.
Anytime painkillers.
You pop in a painkiller.
And then you just drink them.
And then you wait until it.
You know.
Just take into effect.
And then you just start chugging milk down.
Like.
Wouldn't that.
Wouldn't that work?
Or then.
And then.
Tummy hurt.
Just use.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
Lactate.
The.
Like.
The thing that.
Um.
You mean purposely.
No.
I meant like.
You know.
If you're really craving for milk.
Um.
Just chuck a pill in.
And then you just drink it.
Like.
You can't.
It's.
You know.
It's not like.
It's the end of the world.
But yeah.
That's.
I thought that was.
I thought that was pretty interesting.
Like.
Fun milk facts.
Guys.
Anton.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lubu drank his milkies.
That's why he grew up.
Big and strong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Robbins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You have to put in work to be a freak.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Our ancestors didn't suck on cow, did he?
Well, not mine, apparently.
But... not mine, because I can safely consume milk.
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Funny how yesterday's stream brought many curse topic.
Classy, dokiest moment.
Can't wait for the next two parts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't kink shame our ancestors.
I mean...
Look, I'm not kink shaming...
Look, I'm kink shaming my ancestors.
And I think they'll be okay with it.
I think...
Um...
Adria, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
What?
I'm just saying...
I'm not being racist.
I'm talking about milk facts.
Because I'm saying that like...
How come...
Like...
Um...
A reason why Asians...
A lot of Asians get lactose intolerant...
Is because they're not used to drinking milk.
Because it...
Milk wasn't like a common thing.
Uh...
Milk and like...
Dairy products wasn't common in Asia.
So I'm just saying...
That like...
But what...
If...
You know...
You know the rest of the world drink a lot of milk.
Some...
I...
I'm saying...
Well...
But the rest of the world...
They were ingesting milk...
Left and...
That's why...
I'm saying guys...
Um...
Oh yeah, oh yeah, because the Mongolians, the Mongolians drank a lot of milk too, right?
So like, so like the Mongolians, basically, oh my god, maybe, oh wait, that's not a good thought.
Like, there's, there's, there's only, there's only one reason why I would have, like, partial Mongolian ancestry.
There's, there's, I just realized that's not a good thing.
There's, there's, um, Betty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The same as most of us, right?
Um, since you're not lactose intolerant, does that mean your ancestors drank everyone else's milk in Asia?
Yeah, well, if I have, like, Mongolian ancestry, um, which is, like, a lot of, a lot of people, um, in China, um, then that means it's because, like, my ancestor just drank horse milk.
Because I guess they're like, fuck water.
They, they have a lot of horses, so, um, um, they have a lot of horses, so, like, I won't be surprised.
Also, give me a sec, I need to, like, register for this real quick.
Um, so, like, uh, but, but, but, I need to register for, wait, they just lifted it, right?
Okay, exciting news, we are removing NDA restrictions.
Oh, okay.
All right, so, um, so, you know how, like, Marathon, look, guys, lucky for you, lucky for you, uh, uh, uh, I can change the topic because I just got pinged for something, which is Marathon.
Um, so, you guys know how Bungie is developing a new game?
Uh, like, literally, they just pinged everyone and be like, oh, any, any restrictions have now been removed.
Yeah, so, um, I received, like, a creator care package from Marathon.
I was so confused because I was like, what the fuck is it?
Because, like, okay, the box itself of the creator package of the Marathon box, I got it, like, two days ago.
I was so confused because I forgot that they asked me about it, like, because they asked me if they, they, they were, they wanted to send this to me, like, three months ago.
And I forgot about it because it was three months ago.
So, so, I received the box for Marathon and, and, like, there was no branding that it was for Marathon.
It had, like, it had, like, the most cryptic shit ever on the box and inside the box.
I was so fucking confused.
I was like, what is this?
I was like, who sent this to me?
And, because I sent it to, like, um, I sent my address, uh, since it was, like, a game package.
So, I said, I'm okay with sending it to my address.
Um, and then, so, in the box, it says, you will not, what was it?
Something escaped, you will not escape God or something.
Okay.
You will, okay, escape God.
I need to remember that quote, what, what that quote was.
It was, it was so, oh, escape will make me God.
I was so, it was just plastered everywhere.
Like, escape will make me God.
And I was like, the fuck is this?
Like, I was so confused.
I was like, what is, what is this package that I received?
So, I had to Google it.
And, obviously, it led me to a marathon.
I was like, what's the fuck?
Why do I have a, oh, yeah, it's that game that's coming out soon.
And there's, like, early access.
And so, um, I looked at our emails, my business email.
And, apparently, um, eight days, nine days ago, they sent me an email to the creator discord server.
And I was, and I, whoops, I missed out on, like, a lot of stuff.
So, after now, I have to sign up.
Because, like, if I joined at the time that I was supposed to join, I would guarantee an early access code.
But because I, you know, I, I didn't realize they sent me the, uh, creator discord.
Um, I have to, um, I have to sign up for it now.
So, it's not guaranteed, though.
Uh, it's not actually guaranteed.
Because I didn't co-stream the reveal or whatever.
Because you're supposed to co-stream the reveal to guarantee a, or co-stream the reveal or talk about it to guarantee an early access code.
And then I was like, oopsie.
So, but I'm still in the discord server.
And they did send me a care package for it.
So, I just need a, um, I just need a, uh, see if I can get it by applying.
So, we'll be coming soon for those that have, that filled out the survey.
Okay, please.
Okay, I did it.
I filled it out.
Yay.
Um.
Um, I heard that, um, I heard that, like, I don't know, it's an extraction shooter.
But it is developed by Bungie, who've made, like, what?
They made Destiny, right?
That's the, yeah, yeah, that they made Destiny and everything.
So, it can't be that bad.
I think the only thing is that, the only thing I'm like, eh, is the fact that, um, oh, and Halo, too.
They did Halo, and, yeah, they made Halo and Destiny.
And, like, the only issue I have with, with Marathon is the fact that, um, it's, uh, it's the fact that, like, it is a partial, a partial extraction shooter.
And I'm, like, really done.
I'm so done with video games doing extraction shooters as, like, their new job.
It's, like, the new Battle Royale, but I feel like, even then, I feel like Battle Royale has, um, has made, has more people playing versus extraction shooters.
So, I don't know, I just feel like, I just feel like, at least Battle Royale had a bigger player base versus, like, Battle Royale type games have bigger player base than extraction shooters.
Extraction shooters die faster.
But yeah, I'm just really done with extraction shooters and stuff.
So we'll see how it goes.
But people were like, no, no, no.
Marathon is different.
It's gonna be different.
They're gonna add a twist to it.
And I'm just thinking like, that's all extraction shooters.
Every extraction shooter right now that's coming out is basically extraction shooter, but a twist.
That's all of them!
Like, what do you mean?
How would this be different?
They all say that.
And they all still die.
Jakato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's the same picture.
Also speaking of Marathon, the OG Marathon trilogy recently released on Steam for free, with Steam Workshop.
Support good pre-Halo bungee shooter.
Thank you for the super chat, Jakato.
Thank you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
When you play a pony game, that was Genghis Khan smiling on his descendant as a freaking act.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, speaking of ponies, did you know that, like, My Little Pony has, like, a second resurgence, but only in China?
I think it's because, like, they started running the show.
I think they started running the show in dubbed, in, like, you know, dubbed Chinese in China.
And, like, there's so many new products of, like, My Little Pony, like, dedicated to, like...
Yeah, there's, like, it's, like, how, you know, it's, like, how Tom and Jerry is, like, incredibly popular in Asia now.
Versus, like, you know, the rest of the world.
And, like, it's happening to, like, My Little Pony at the moment.
Like, My Little Pony is getting incredibly popular in Asia, specifically in China.
And there's, like, they've released, like, exclusive Chinese merch.
Just, you can only get in China or, like, get expensive, like, overseas shipment to you.
But it's, like, there's, like, yeah, they released a TCG of My Little Pony, but it's only in Chinese.
Like, that's how popular it is.
Like, an entirely new TCG is being made in China.
I was, like, I saw, like, lots of, like, merch pictures of it.
Because people were, like, you know, the bronies were, like, I'm happy for you.
But, like, you know, the mad emoji, like this one.
They're, like, they're, like, they're, like, I'm happy for you.
And there's, like, a ton of, there's, like, a ton of really, like, really good merch just specifically released there.
Um, so I thought, like, like, even, like, plushies and...
And they're higher quality.
I think the most, the most fucked up part is that it's incredibly higher quality than whatever the fuck Hasbro has released in NA.
Okay, I'll do a comparison.
I'll show you guys a comparison.
So, um, so, okay.
So, you know, like, NA TCG cards, they're mostly, like, screenshots of the shows.
Uh, so, like, they're...
Yeah, Hasbro is Hasbro.
So, here's a comparison.
So, you can tell, like...
So, this is, like, TCG for an NA.
So, they're mostly always done.
They're mostly, like...
This is what I hate about, like, TCGs based off of, like, shows and stuff.
Is that they just use screenshots.
So, this is, like, the regular TCG.
And then, like, in China, they actually use, like...
The China TCG of My Little Pony.
I almost said My Little Brony.
They use, like, actual original art.
Okay.
Yeah, so, it's, like, you can tell, like, the difference between, like, the quality of the...
So, yeah.
Oh, what the...
There's, like, actual...
Like, they actually hired artists to make original art.
For, like, the trading cards.
So, you can tell the quality is a lot different.
So, people...
So, all, like, the NA fans are just, like...
I'm happy for you.
But, you know they're not happy.
You know...
You know they're not happy at all.
I thought it was incredibly interesting.
It was, like...
It was crazy.
I looked at the merch and I was just, like...
Wait, that's, like...
That's actually, like...
Like, good merch.
Because Hasbro...
Hasbro...
Okay, the thing about Hasbro is that...
You know how, like, they make...
You know, they make shows out of their products?
But the thing is...
They want to make sure it looks like the molds that they have.
So, they can reuse the molds...
Over and over and over again.
For, like, you know, peak profits.
So, they just, like, use the same molds and everything.
And they just, like, change one or two little things.
And then...
So, they do that for Transformers.
They do that for...
Transformers.
They do that for Barbie.
They do that for, like...
You know, uh...
Mild Pony.
And they don't, like...
For majority of their properties.
Like, the reason why...
For He-Man...
Like, back then...
Like, where all the characters looked the same.
You know, like, the figures and everything.
Like, the...
The guys are all, like...
Super buff men, and then the women are like super sexy and everything, but like the same build.
It's because they use two molds.
Guy mold and woman mold.
And they just make new accessories.
That's really it.
They all look the same.
It's just they have different hair or different accessories.
Because it's all... they only have two molds.
It's male-female.
And so like they do that.
So even now they do that for like the newer property.
Like they haven't changed in their ways.
And so like... so that's why like, you know, they put a lot less effort when it comes to...
when it comes to merch.
Because they know children don't really care.
Like, it's true though.
Like, kids don't really care.
If a kid... also like in today's world, if a child buys an actual toy, that's a success there already.
Like, I... I... I... I don't think children play toys anymore.
If you get a child to buy an actual toy...
then like, congratulations, you made it.
Like...
So... so... I feel like... like...
Um, they are putting even less effort due to the fact that, um, who buys toys anymore?
They are better than iPads, no, 100%.
It's just that we live in a day and age where a child would not play a toy, uh, would not want to play toys because, like, their parents are, some parents are, like, super lazy and they just give them an iPad, even though, like, okay, you know, okay, I'm jumping through.
I just realized I've been talking for, whoops, I've been talking for 48 minutes!
I haven't played the game yet!
Oh, alright, this is the last topic.
Um, but, like, people don't realize because, okay, so, like, the earlier, when iPads first came out, you know, people were like, oh, it won't hurt the child if I make them look at iPads and everything.
But, like, obviously, there's not no data to, to actually research into the effects of giving a child an iPad and what happens to the brain to the child's development when they keep watching the, when they watch the screen.
So, like, now, after, like, 10 plus years, we actually finally have data on what happens when you provide children with electronics at an earlier age.
And who would have thought it actually stops development?
It actually hinders, um, development for the brain because you don't have, you know, a child's brain, uh, like, the brain is being developed the most when you're a child.
And who would have thought, if you give your child an iPad, it actually slows down development?
And, and, um, it actually affects, like, attention span and everything.
So, you know, not the greatest.
It's just, like, Ozempic, where, uh, you know, people were like, no, it's so fine.
People were like, it's okay to use Ozempic.
Uh, the only side effects, you know, because there's not enough data right now or, or years to actually calculate what the actual long-term effects it is for, for Ozempic.
And people were like, it's okay, guys.
Oh, the only side effects of Ozempic is that you don't eat as much.
But now, like, data is already coming in.
Uh.
This is already coming in, where, like, um, some of the effects of Ozempic is not...
It's not very good side effects.
Ozempic hasn't been around?
Nope, yes, but then they weren't using it as a diet drug.
That's the thing.
They were used for, like, diabetics and other, like, ill sicknesses.
But now, it's people without diabetes are using it.
And people, they don't have enough data on what happens to people who are not diabetic and are using Ozempic.
It's actually, like, crazy that people are just, you know, stabbing themselves with a needle.
Just because they're like, okay, but I get to be skinnier.
Like, never, exactly, never be the first one to try anything related to medical, to medical items.
Um, but all for collecting data, guys!
Woo!
Data time!
Alright.
Anyway.
Anyway, time to actually play the game.
Yippee!
But yeah, it's actually crazy that, like, Um, people didn't, people are like, let's give children iPads.
And we'll see how it goes.
Whoa, surprise!
Surprise!
They developed, they did not develop well.
Alright, anyway.
Yay!
Okay, so I don't know how long this is gonna take for me.
Uh, how long this is gonna take for me to complete this game.
For those who don't know, Friday Night Fortress vs.
Manco.
Um, is a Friday Night Funkin' mod.
I played this mod last time when I was playing my own fan-made mod, the Tomato Funkin', and then, like, I finished it, and then I was just like, alright, I'm gonna, I'm gonna look at different mods, because I still have time.
And, this is, this, this one was incredibly hard.
Um, it was incredibly hard, and I did not complete a single level.
And, because there is no difficulty slider for this game.
There is no, there was no difficulty slider.
So, I'm actually going straight up playing on hard mode.
So, I end the stream, the moment I beat one singular level.
Uh, I swear to God, if I beat this level within 20 minutes, after talking for, like, 45 minutes, they'll be like, wow, Doki did struggle for it, and then they'll just see me on the fucking screen for 45 minutes, and then...
And then the game, like, and then they're like, wait, she's not even playing the game.
No, I told myself, I will only, I will stop after I beat one level.
Like, I can't, I...
This game...
This game made me rage so hard.
I don't think...
I cannot...
I cannot do more than one.
Alright, let me...
I hope the volume is okay.
I did look at my...
Soundgat might need your help with checking the volume for this later.
Uh, or, like, soon.
Alright, free play unlocked.
Okay.
Demoman was the easiest.
I need to get warmed up for this.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
I actually almost joined the Discord.
It always...
Almost...
Gets me into the Discord.
Almost.
How do I play the game?
Oh, activate.
Okay.
When I press space bar, it, like, tries to put me in the Discord.
I was like, no, I don't want to join your goddamn Discord.
No, it wasn't Demoman.
Get me out.
Get me...
It was a Demoman.
It was...
Miss Pauling.
Miss Pauling was the easiest.
I...
I remember.
I saw him and I was like, no, no, no.
No.
Miss Pauling.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Bump.
Okay, the switcheroo.
The switcheroo was the hardest part.
The switcheroo was the one I struggled the most.
Oh, wait.
That's not me.
This is me.
Oh, my God.
I can't...
I'm already, like...
Buttons go so fast.
Oh, my
God.
I'm not used to pressing buttons right now.
It's already really fast for me.
I forgot.
The chat is, like, Ashley Team Fortress.
The game experience.
Oh, my God.
This is the easy level, too.
I'm doing okay for the easy level.
Oh, oh, okay.
Never mind.
No, you're right.
I got a little bit too confident.
And the game was like, yeah, bet.
Alright.
Okay, there's Demoman.
Demoman.
Get out!
Leave!
Oh, no.
Not Demoman.
Okay.
Ah!
I'm not doing okay.
I forgot when Demoman comes in.
Things get really rough.
Please give me lines.
That's the only way I survive.
Oh, no.
I'm not okay right now.
That's the...
Oh!
Lines are the only way I can survive.
Oh, turn down the audio a little bit.
Okay.
I'll turn it down.
Alright.
Let me know if it's better.
Okay.
I forgot.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
This game.
Okay.
It's...
It's only Demoman.
It's literally Demoman.
Oh, I...
That's Miss Pauline.
I keep forgetting.
At least the song's really good, too.
It's literally Demoman that makes it harder.
Oh, they just need to give me lines.
Okay.
It's okay.
Alright, sound good.
How's the sound now?
And my fingers have to get warmed up, too, for this game.
Fuck!
Okay.
At least it's not the scout's level.
Scout's level was actually bullshit.
I am not doing that one.
Fuck, three up so high.
Oh boy, I love this chat system.
Oh, it's so fast.
Oh no!
How did I do this before?
Okay, I'll move it up a little bit.
I got into the switcherun!
I don't remember how I got it!
My hands are just... my fingers are not...
My fingers are not fast enough right now.
What if I start mashing?
Okay, it's not good.
It's like, bad!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's not as bad now!
Who- who was not- mashing was not it?
Alright, three misses.
Not as- not as bad.
No!
Jesus Christ.
I don't know how fucking rhythm gamers do this daily and they actually like walk out to the arcade and to also do rhythm games.
They go outside.
Rhythm gamers are like a whole new level.
They actually go outside to play their rhythm games sometimes.
How do they do that?
It's fun.
Rhythm gamers are the strongest of us all.
They actually touch grass to play their rhythm games sometimes.
No.
No!
I'm always stuck here.
Okay, I'm locking in.
I'm locking in.
I'm okay with the miss ball in level.
It's just Demoman.
Crap.
The administrator is gonna kill me.
Okay, lock in.
It's literally Demoman.
Someone fucking take him back to Scotland.
He's too drunk.
Okay.
Like I can do it at that speed!
I said like take him back to Scotland to visit his family.
He needs a vacation.
I don't know what you guys thought.
He needs a vacation so he can mellow out.
So that's...
to check him out.
We'll be right back in.
We'll
be right back in.
Freak!
Psyched out!
Oh, fuck!
Sorry!
I'm just saying what Soldier would say, which is something I shouldn't say.
Guys, I'm just being immersed in the world of TFT.
No!
Goddammit!
Stop reading this.
Never say anything Soldier would say.
Okay.
Yeah, but he got a hot wife in the end.
Guys, he got a hot wife and like lots of children.
And they live like in the mines.
How am I getting worse?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, and then he got Heavy as a brother-in-law.
Like, that guy made it.
He's made it.
Yeah, muscle mommy wife and two children.
And the fact that Heavy is his brother-in-law.
And what does Demoman have afterwards?
Nothing.
His alcohol.
It's not fair.
All I'm saying is that Demoman in the future got nothing.
Other than his one eye.
Oh
my god, this part is so difficult.
He got his alcohol though.
He's beating you.
That's all you need.
Just give me more lines.
That's literally how I can survive.
Also, is the game better now?
Volume one?
Sound guess?
No.
It's literally this part!
It's literally the...
Ah!
I cannot get past!
That's always there!
How does the other sound end, boy?
Every single time.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm focusing for real this time.
Well, at least this...
At least this song's good, at least.
So I can replay it over and over again.
Ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba.
Ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum.
I'm locking it, I'm locking it!
Why can't they give me more lines?!
Jesus Christ!
Okay.
Please let me play!
I'm losing HP waiting for you, Ms. Pine!
Alright.
Yeah, I, like, nailed that part.
It's literally Demoman.
The milk button ain't enough.
I want him.
Most sane Team Fortress 2 player.
Jesus, no.
I'm gonna die again.
I'm at 20.
No!
Get me out of this hurdle!
The moment I learn this part, it's over.
Get me out of that area!
That's the saving spot!
And this is the easiest!
Release me!
Oh my god, I looked at chat when I started.
Locking in now.
You can't be as out close as you can be me.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Please, I'm just a tiny man.
No, you're not.
That's your gentle?!
That
is gentle!
Oh, no, I'm heading there.
I'm getting my thing is lowering my thing is lowering let me play let me play demo let me play
Kaboom I get this part down so well!
Like, my hands know this part!
They know this part!
They downloaded this part into the brain!
Okay, except for that part.
I repeat the rhythm.
Maybe I start going outside.
Things will get easier.
Just like all the other rhythm gamers.
No, that's too much.
That's actually too much.
Going outside?
That's a little too far.
Doki.
Doki, no!
Too far!
I always lose so much in this area.
Oh, I lose so much HP!
I always lose so much HP!
Doki!
Oh my god!
3, 2, 1, begin!
It
must be mesmerized if you're filming it!
Doki, no!
Doki!
Doki,
no!
Doki, no!
Okay.
Oh, this is the most misses I got for this run.
Ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum.
Oh my god.
Oh, there he is.
Hello, I'm Tiny Man.
That's me.
Tiny Man.
Get ready for a 54 second mic.
Look at the options real quick.
It's always there.
It's always...
It's always the 54 seconds.
Oh my god.
Can I get...
If I have more friends.
Okay.
What if I have more friends?
Alright.
Maybe...
Maybe it'll be easier.
Maybe more frames equals more gaming.
Maybe...
Maybe my framework will save me.
I mean...
Surely...
More frames equals more gaming.
Okay.
If I increased the FOV, it'd get easier, right?
You needed this...
Zero, you needed this...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You needed disassociate.
Alright.
Let me...
Okay.
Is it faster?
Guys, maybe more frames was not it.
Guys, I don't think I like the more frames.
Who would have guessed?
Guys, I don't like this.
I don't like the more frames.
Frames.
Oh, wait.
Some more frames.
My eyes can't follow anymore.
Okay.
What if I do less frames?
We made my cap into third frames.
Wait!
That's 54!
Frames the key!
Oh my god.
Wait!
More frames the key!
It's fine.
It's a flip.
It's a fucking flip.
But more frames the key.
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
More frames!
It is it!
Okay.
I'm locked in.
More frames.
It's Australia real.
DUMBLE MAN!
Oh!
Oh my god.
How am I breathing hard from this?
How am I breathless?
I'm not even outside!
You guys!
What!
It's a friiise!!!
It's over!
Bye!!!